>> Dana: LOTS OF CONCERN DOWN
THERE.
THANK YOU, MIKE TOBIN.
>> Bill: FOR MORE ON HOW THE
WHITE HOUSE PLANS TO ADDRESS THE
CRISIS AND WHAT IT COULD MEAN
FOR A BIDEN RE-ELECTION
CAMPAIGN.
RICHED SOP
RICH --
>> THEY’RE INCREASING
PROSECUTIONS FOR THOSE CROSSING
ILLEGALLY ACCORDING TO AXIOS.
MODERATE DEMOCRATS SAY THE WHITE
HOUSE NEEDS MORE OF THAT
ESPECIALLY AS PRESIDENT BIDEN
CONSIDERS RUNNING FOR
RE-ELECTION.
THEY ARE WARNING THE WHITE HOUSE
THAT REPUBLICANS WILL CAMPAIGN
RELENTLESSLY ON RECORD
ENCOUNTERS AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER DURING HIS TERM AND THEY
ARE TELLING HIM TO CHANGE
COURSE.
>> THE REPUBLICANS, WHOEVER RUNS
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT WILL USE
OPEN BORDERS, ETC. , ETC.
THE WAY THEY USED IT AGAINST
SOME DEMOCRATS.
I THINK HE STILL HAS TIME TO
START REALLY ADDRESSING THE
BORDER IN A COMPASSIONATE WAY
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY YOU
HAVE TO ENFORCE THE LAW.
>> HE SAYS THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
THE TOOLS TO ADDRESS THE BORDER
IN A COMPASSIONATE WAY THOUGH HE
IS NOT SURE IF THEY WILL.
FOX NEWS POLL CONDUCTED A MONTH
FROM THE MID-TERM ELECTIONS
REPUBLICANS HAD A 20 POINT
ADVANTAGE ON ADDRESSING BORDER
SECURITY.
ANALYSTS SAY THE PRESIDENT
ALWAYS HAS TO LOOK BEYOND
HOLDING THE WHITE HOUSE IN 2024.
>> THEY HAVE THE CONTROL OF THE
SENATE AND THE WHITE HOUSE.
THIS IS A NECESSITY NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF THE SUBSTANCE OF THE
ISSUE BUT BECAUSE REPUBLICANS
ARE IN POSITION TO TAKE THE
SENATE IF THE DEMOCRATS DON’T
MODERATE ON A HOST OF ISSUES.
>> IN TWO YEARS AMERICANS WILL
VOTE TO FILL 33 SEATS IN THE
SENATE.
DEMOCRATS CONTROL 23 OF THEM.
A MUCH MORE DIFFICULT LANDSCAPE